if your question is when to rob a bank
which plainly is our questions that's
what we titled the book you think about
a few things you think about you know
time of day day of week you know part of
the year and so on and this grew out of
the fact that I'd read about a bank
robber in New Jersey who was finally
arrested after robbing banks on six
Thursdays and it made me wonder maybe
Thursday is the best day they robbed the
bank maybe he knew something about the
way the bank operated maybe that was his
day off whatever so I went looking into
the bank robbery data itself because
that's kind of what we do is look at
data and see what's interesting and this
one was more you know we weren't
searching for this before the question
arose it turns out that bank robberies
are most the the most common day is
Friday which I guess people make sense
because people think it's payday and
there's a lot a lot of money coming in
going out but that doesn't necessarily
mean you'll be more likely to be
successful on Friday there's really no
big difference in success rates from day
of week but you are much more likely to
get more money if you rob a bank in the
morning than in the afternoon and yet
most bank robbers work in the afternoon
not the morning which leads you to think
well either bank robbers aren't very
good at profit maximizing you know
thinking the way economists do or that
maybe they just can't get up in the
morning go to work bank robbery bank
robbing which means that maybe they
could get up in the morning early in the
first place they wouldn't have to resort
to bank robbery but the the real answer
to when to rob a bank is is never and
never is the right answer because the
ROI or the return on investment on bank
robbery is terrible so if you're going
to become a criminal bank robbery is a
bad crime the average haul is about four
thousand dollars in the US per bank
robbery in the in the UK it's
substantially more so you could consider
that and you're likely to get arrested
after just three bank robberies and sent
to prison so you have to think as a
career move bank robbery is really
dreadful and then one other tangent that
we got involved with on this and looking
into bank robberies is um internal you
know internal inside jobs and when the
most interesting ones we came across was
a woman in Iowa who for years
years and years had been embezzling
money from a bank about two million
dollars worth and it was actually the
bank was actually owned the president of
Bank was her father interestingly so I
don't know what the dynamics were there
she was finally caught and it turns out
that she had kept two sets of books
which is kind of how you want to
embezzle and she was exhausted when she
was caught the reason she was exhausted
because she'd worked so hard she'd never
taken a vacation over all those years
and the reason was that she was scared
too so she took a vacation someone would
find that she'd been keeping two sets of
books and she would have been found out
so it was interesting as she went to
prison for a few years she was let let
out she moved back in with her parents
who were obviously very forgiving since
it was the dad's bank that she had kind
of put into trouble and then she was put
then she went to work with law
enforcement only someone who knows how
to cheat or how to steal or had a lie or
rob would know how to help the good guys
catch the bad guys from doing it so she
went to work for law enforcement and
they found that one of the best metrics
to look for in preventing white-collar
crime generally an embezzlement
particular was people who took who
didn't take vacations or who took really
strange vacations so if in your firm you
see that someone is passing up on their
vacation time you shouldn't necessarily
think of them as just like a super hard
worker or an altruist to your company
you might want to take a look in their
drawer and see if they're keeping a
second set of books